okay now what is your opinion on eric
weinstein's geometric unity have you had
a chance to go through any of the papers
no
no i should i'm sorry i i should but i
don't i i i could not follow my opinion
okay that's fine how about
donald hoffman's have you do you know
donald hoffman
so he has
the case against reality and yours is
called reality is not what it seems
yes oh this is a big philosophical
discussion um
he definitely have
um
a number of very good points
um
and some
radical conclusions from
from those
um
i i know about a little bit about his
ideas but i have not read his book so
i'm not sure i have a
good uh gauging of exactly what you want
to draw
from that
um
but let me let me say the core of of
what i think um
we
interact
with the external world around us
through um our senses and to our uh um
the way the brain
interprets
um
what we see around us
and uh
i think it's
uh
a a very good and and very deep
observation
to um
recognize to realize that we call what
we call the objects
around us
are to a large extent
mental constructs
that
our brain
puts together
uh on the basis of how
useful
uh
this construct has been in our evolution
to to
uh to allow us to to survive
so uh
in in
in a sense we're we're seeing a movie of
what is outside which is vaguely related
to what is outside whatever it's
happening outside
and is deeply um
colored by our reading of it um
this is uh this is an observation which
has been made in philosophy uh
many times in fact it's one of the main
things for which kant uh is known
and kant is considered a major
philosopher in
the western tradition but
it's it's others
others before and after have
have made this observation
and i think it's important uh because
what we're describing at every level is
not the world it's a world of
perspective it's the world aspect
right
um
and i think this this has to be deeply
into your eyes even if it seems what has
the natural reaction of that i mean
there's a chair there and of course i
mean i'm saying well come on the chair
is there independently for me and
there's a sense in which this is not
true
uh the chair is my particular reading of
what is going on for a number of reasons
for a
variety of reasons that he he goes in
details in the very right
so the disagreement is
now so far i'm i'm completely with him
uh
now the two points
one is that all right so what
um
then what
um
and there's two points i would not
really object but i would
say how i think about this first of all
that this does not mean
that our mental world
is more
solid and known than the external
because exactly the same arguments
uh employed here for the external world
exactly the same arguments work for our
mental world namely
there is nothing certain either
in what we see as our sense of our self
or perception these are also
complicated the
uh
cultural biological construction
that our representation of the world
has so our competition for the world
include the notion of myself and also my
representations also my representations
which are all notions that were
developed culturally
so the same criticism
against the existence of outside objects
i think hold
for the existence of
the self
uh and my mental world
okay
so this leaves us where
i think and this is my my arrival point
this leaves us in my opinion
toward
the anti-foundationalism
that we talked at the beginning of the
story
namely we should not ask the wrong
question the wrong question is what is
really really really outside there
that's a wrong question
the right question
is um
[Music]
i see
a mirror
okay
it seems to me that a chair is the other
side of the mirror
is it true or false no it's false is an
illusion the chair is not the other side
of the mirror the chair is here
okay
the chair is really here and falsely
outside the mirror that's correct
okay
we can play this game step by step by
realizing that things are not like that
we're misunderstanding there there's a
better way of understanding that
they're not like that the
misunderstanding there's a matter with
if we ask the question okay so what is
the ultimate reality
independently of any representation
that's not a good question in my opinion
that's a wrong question
reality is that share reality is that
sun the reality is that sharing the
mural
and their relations their relative
relations
so i will jump out of this discussion
okay and
distinguish if you want the apparent
reality and the ultimate reality and
forget about the ultimate reality we are
talking about this after reality and
that's what we call reality
reality is the ensemble
of this phenomena of which i am part and
your part and the chair is part
and all the way we
understand better and better and better
we can say they are made by atoms for
fantastic we can say the atoms are
a quantum mechanical object that
interact with us fantastic we we get
more and more complexity of the
phenomena
but we
if we get if we ask the question
where do we ground all that what is the
ultimate reality forget about this so if
the case against reality
that he's making
is the case is the case against the idea
of an ultimate reality out there
and in favor of an ultimate reality for
our
impressions i disagree
because there's a good way of
understanding our impression as caused
by the chair
that chair
not
a metaphysical chair
or if you want in kantian terms who
cares about the nominee
we care about the phenomena
what we call reality is a phenomena not
an
hypothetical thing
behind the phenomena
that's my take on it
when i hear that well here's what i'm
thinking okay you said the chair is not
really behind the mirror it's really
over to the left of me
okay yeah
and that's what it means really
right we have this notion of really we
have this notion of reality then if i
was to get you or anyone else just say
people in general to what are some facts
that of what is a part of reality see
we're trying to derive a definition from
looking at well i say that this
microphone is really in front of me and
then i may point to other objects
and say that really is the case but then
well what if there's an inconsistency in
what we call a part of our reality and
not then which one do we take as more
why do we favor this microphone being
really in front of me but
santa claus not really exists no you
have you have i got i got exactly the
point i think we have to use really
coherence just which ones mix cohere
together consistent what is it
i i think we have to realize that uh
really in reality
it's uh uh it can be used in different
uh right right right to use at different
levels and it's fine we do a different
level for instance um
did
hamlet
really killed his uncle
yes he did really kill his uncle i mean
um if you tell me you know hamlet did
not kill his uncle at the end of the
play i said no no he did he really did
look i come with shakespeare texts i
said it's written here i'm killing you
uncle bonk okay
so i'm using really
okay
okay uh it's it's real
and now you tell me come on it's not
real because it's a play see of course
it's not real
okay
so when am i right when i say i'm real
when i say i'm right in both cases i'm
just meaning two different reviews so
real is in a context
if you want to take real outside the
questions what is really really really
real
behind all the context
that has no meaning
so talking about the mirror we make a
distinction between the chair on the
other side of the mirror and the chair
that chair there
and
that distinction it's meaningful and we
correctly use one to be real and one not
to be real and i can argue exactly what
i mean i i mean if i walk against the
mirror i just
hit my nose against the moon well if i
walk there that chair i can sit down i
mean just
there's a very precise sense in which
one is more real than the other
okay and in the in if i'm dreaming
there's a very precise sense in which i
say that's not real it was a dream
okay
but within the dream itself there i
think which are real in the dream and
not real in the dream okay in the dream
i can dream of somebody who is telling
me uh i mean look you thought that is so
bad is not so the real something else so
within the dream there is a notion of
reality there in the movie there is a
notion of reality there
so
the question of what is real is a very
slippery question it's a
context by context it makes sense
but every time we see a context
in which
we're giving something for granted and
we're building
and when
when i hear the
argument um
look
uh
the
the way my brain
makes sense of that chair it's because
in my brain there is a notion of sitting
there is an ocean because there is a
space of colors blah blah blah blah
and therefore
uh the chair it's it's it's it's really
a cherry
in an illusion for me
the context is a context in which i'm
giving for real a number of things my
brain
the the the the the most the the the
the the existence of light coming to me
you're creating a context so that within
that context there's a notion of reality
and and and and illusion
and what about that context itself is it
real is not real
it's
i i think that we describe the phenomena
that we interact with
and within description that's the
scripture is reality that's what we mean
by reality
and if we try to say
uh
beyond the phenomena
what is the true ultimate reality we're
making a mistake
and this is a mistake
that a lot of philosophers
have warned us against many
hume can't
careful
i mean you take a distinction
the chair in the mirror and the chair
you see there
and you try to replay that
that's everything you know about the
universe and something else which is a
real real real thing that's really
really think forget about it don't don't
do that
so i would say
that
we're not a case against reality
with a case for reality
and against the idea that there's an
ultimate reality behind it beyond
everything
when you say that what i'm wondering is
is that because we can never know what's
outside of what's knowable so you gave
kant the phenomenon the pneumonia give
that example is it because of that we
can just not know it why is it that
it's so foolish to talk about the
foundational reality
uh to the extent in which we can know
something else we may hope to know
something else we we correctly
put this question
uh on the table
right
uh but only to the extent in which we
may have a hope
to know something else
um
i'll explain my reasoning behind the
question
and me so when i'm speaking to some
non-dualist i don't know if you know
what non-dualism is
they would say consciousness is primary
and then i pose the question well how do
you know what if there's something
outside consciousness a simple question
they would say yeah but you could never
know that
well
it's true i can't experience what's
outside my experience by definition
but that to me doesn't mean that it
doesn't exist now you one can say that
it's foolish to talk about it because it
never interacts with you and you have no
clue that's another argument but to say
it doesn't exist
because it's outside of our experience i
don't find that particularly convincing
so that's what's behind my question
no no it's it's it it's a good question
uh i i i see the point
um uh
we
what is the use
of
of imagining
that there is something beyond our
knowledge
okay i think there are two uses
one is that
because perhaps we may get to know it
the other is just you know to recognize
that i mean who knows it might be or
that might not be something
and
these are two very different situations
uh
namely uh
if if i see a chair and i suspect that
it might be in understandable in terms
of atoms
i can
ask the question
uh maybe beyond the appearance of the
chair there is a there is a atomic
structure
and then i can do some science or i can
do some investigation or can do b
boltzmann and come up with explanation
of temperature on the basis of
that or be einstein and come up with a
brown emotion and from the atoms
explained by an emotion or then you know
be ibm that make a microscope and see
the atoms
so
beyond some appearances i suspected that
there was some reality
uh a better deeper
um
description reality and that allowed me
to get a better escape from the world
that's
it's a situation in which is good to say
well
maybe i just don't know something which
i might know it
but if the argument
uh
like the case against reality is that
there is a reality which is in principle
unknowable
that they cannot know about that
which is a completely different story is
to say uh
maybe there is an aspect of
beyond what we call reality usually
which is
in principle and accessible
and then what interest do we have on
that on that
i mean why should we talk about that
i mean suppose uh you know i come to you
and say you know i believe that this is
a universe but there's a next to another
direct dimension where there are you
know green dragons going around and
speaking chinese to one another okay but
they never interact with us we never
interact with them and uh
and they just totally
and then you say how do you know about
that i mean i don't but can you disprove
it no i cannot disprove it but what's
the interest of this story zero
so i think that ultimate reality is like
dragons
speaking chinese to one another and
playing football in another dimension
we should not talk about
by reality we mean what we interact with
with the complexity
of the different layers
and we may find other layers perfectly
but we shouldn't worry about
this
uh not being the totality of things
because that's the totality of things
we're interested about